em 2017 fala viajando para Belo
Horizonte para visitar um amigo meu e
nessa viagem ou fazer com uma obra um
desenho bem simples que o direito de
hoje é o começo de toda essa minha
reflexão o desenho Era esse ele fala
precisamos repensar a condição dos
não-humanos nas cidades exagerar
ambiental na época fala trabalhando com
o organismo é só falta ela me marcou
desenho de mulher curte vários elementos
chamavam a atenção mas que na época não
entendia muito bem aqui do início uma
reação foi que brisa Eu tava viajando
com esse meu amigo que é engenheiro
civil e com ele para ele com certeza foi
Nossa isso é uma brisa muito louca mas
ela me deixou com a pulga atrás da
orelha eram pautas que a gente
geralmente nos escute umas palavras
estranhas que a gente geralmente não usa
a gente fala de cidade a gente pensa
logo no ano a cidade é nosso lar né ele
tem que ter um estranho no meio né
e esses não humanos esses desenhos são
árvores parece que essas áreas estão em
fazer um panelaço manifestação para nós
vai comprar uns esquilos e umas Pombas
lá na praça do mercadão para a gente
reivindicar o direito deles Só que os
dias depois eu não tenho que pensando
mas e aí de verdade como anda essa
relação da natureza com a nossa cidade
com nós humanos na época trabalhava com
consultoria em sustentabilidade
mobilidade principalmente para
prefeituras e eu me dei conta que o
setor de vez de Meio Ambiente dessas
prefeituras conhecidas as cidades de
outras que eu já tinha visto na vida se
resume em alguns tópicos bem específicos
que era poda Capina coleta de resíduos e
controle de pragas e quando a gente
olhava para o passado essas mesmas
cidades as mesmas sociedades eles já
tinham removido quase todas as árvores
canalizado rios tampado nascentes aí
hoje que acontece vem a chuva a
a outra e a praça no Mercadão lá onde
nossos água estava se manifestando e
levado embora e no fim do dia a gente
xinga natureza gente xinga chuva aí te
ignora que fomos nós mesmos que
eliminamos a condição de vida da cidade
e que levamos explorar acontecesse e a
gente acha que é um piscinão de milhões
de reais que tiver construir que vai
resolver uma visão bem simples fica na
época essa essa reflexão levou a
concluir que a gente encarava natureza e
os não-humanos comprada como o elemento
que a gente tem que controlar e não um
elemento a gente tem que se relacionar e
o antropólogo francês que eu gosto
bastante chama Felipe da Escola que ele
fala a caneta a vida ela é feita de
ervas e interdependentes sendo que
alguns desses elos Eles não estão vivos
e dentro dessa cadeia nós humanos a
gente não pode separar tanto já falarem
nós não faz muito sentido quando nós
somos compostos exteriores deles Como as
bactérias é absurdo e pensar
o Chaves de lado para viver uma bolha
diz ele ao mesmo tempo quando tem que
falar isso números mostram realmente o
oposto Né desde 1500 até 2020 15 20 anos
pelo menos 680 espécies de vertebrados
foram extintas diretamente pela ação
humana processo de extinção ele é um
processo que existe na natureza porém se
a velocidade ela tá sendo cerca de 10 a
100 vezes maiores do que todas as outras
extinções em massa do nosso
Olá hoje nós somos em média sete. Oito
bilhões de humanos do planeta é muita
gente mas se a gente for pensar em massa
né em peso a nós humanos apresentam só
0,01 por cento da massa que vira o
planeta você três vezes mais do que
outros animais selvagens mamíferos
selvagens porém a são de longe muito
inferiores sobre o a massa viva dessa
desse lugar que eu tinha uma terra as
plantas representam oitenta e dois por
cento as bactérias doze por cento e os
vírus que ficaram famosos no ano passado
eles têm quatro vezes mais em peso do
que a gente não vocês Imaginem vírus
para tudo quanto é lado porém nossos pés
se insistimos em não enxergar como a
principal espécies planeta e mesmo a
gente tenta comprou a tudo que vive que
não viu e como aquele desenho que fazia
alusão né A cidade é um espelho de sua
função da condição dos não humanos na
cidade reflete como somos nós humanos
hoje nosso planeta a França com o país
por exemplo
é uma população mais ou menos estável
que organiza tanto ela urbanizarte
fiscaliza por ano cerca de 65 mil
hectares de solo e se a mesma coisa que
a gente falar aqui nove São Carlos São
criadas novas São Carlos para São de
natureza a espaço humana agora imagine a
esses números no Brasil é o número dessa
transformação que a gente tem grande
crescimento ainda nossa sociedade é uma
espécie engenheira e falar isso para um
público que deve ter bastante Engenheiro
é um pouco redundante mas essa
engenharia ela coloca a gente no topo e
muitas cadeias alimentares né ela coloca
existe um controle mas o que ia falar de
engenharia de uma perspectiva um
pouquinho diferente falar de engenharia
da mudança do espaço físico né a gente
constrói muita coisa a gente consegue
cidade transforma a matéria a gente
empilha a gente cola porém outras
espécies também fazem isso né Umas coisa
muito legal é o pastor eles são uma
espécie engenheira muito boa Eles fazem
em barragens nos rios para criar a casa
deles e para facilitar o acesso
o único a diferença dessa engenharia do
castor e do ser humano o pastor ele muda
o ecossistema sistema Ecológico criando
uma cadeia alimentar criando um novo
ecossistema deixou nessa costela mais
complexo ele cria condições para a vida
já a nossa engenharia ela geralmente
cria condições para a morte
e vai mostrar essa relação humana um
pouco deturpada com a natureza tem uma
outra foto que eu tirei também uma
viagem minha mas essa ver se o Nordeste
que retrata também a natureza é uma
representação da época colonial
portuguesa a representando o esse ente
mitológico natureza né a que a gente vai
ter é a natureza retratada como
provedora imagem Maternal que alimenta
que nos dá ferramentas né onde a gente
vem servir essa separação entre humano e
natureza ou natureza cultura por
Ecologia é uma dualidade antiga aqui foi
muito reforçada pelo pela Revolução
Industrial do sistema econômico
capitalista né que não inclui a natureza
as contas cultura somos nós humanos e
aqui o reforço Nossa espécie homo
sapiens sapiens né temos pensamentos
sentimentos e inteligência EA natureza é
o resto que provém a gente que serve a
gente e no máximo que a gente vai usar
como um modelo ideal
I had inspiração e o foge controla as
parte do pressuposto que nada natureza
tem muita lógica nem muita cultura EA
gente esquece que a gente também a
natureza né O que a gente tem uma
ligação profunda inegável que tudo que
Vivi e não viver nesse planeta sem
matureza com saúde não tem como tomar e
dar uma humanidade com saúde nós temos
um planeta temos uma saúde é impossível
falar de tudo isso natureza homem de
impacto e não pensava a definição da
sustentabilidade né quando a gente pensa
assim estabilidade da gente age na mente
aquele tripé da sustentabilidade aqueles
três termos que a gente tem que tentar
equilibrar aí encontrar essa esse aqui
perfeito entre a economia a sociedade e
o meio ambiente mas eu queria chamar
atenção que até nessa definição a gente
tem essa dualidade ela tem impregnada de
qualidade a gente não consegue enxergar
mais equilíbrio ainda hoje né a mais que
a gente vai ter um lado meio ambiente e
do outro lado tudo dimensões
o que o sistema social e que é o sistema
econômico a gente tenta equilibrar eles
mas o que a gente vá conhecer a gente
vai Observar se você falar para qualquer
profissional da área sustentabilidade
ele vai falar que Poxa a gente tenta
bastante mas no final do dia a parte
meio ambiente fica fragilizada ou a
gente acaba privilegiando sistema social
e sistema econômico né e geralmente Sem
falar que não é todos os humanos são
beneficiados nessa história são solos
tem uma outra abordagem dessa dessa
noção assim que habilidade que é um
pouquinho diferente ela coloca a isso
uma perspectiva diferente né que
entender o meio ambiente como base então
uma grande única bola no naquelas três
Barrinhas a sustentabilidade dentro dele
tem um sistema social e dentro do
sistema social que é uma outra invenção
que o sistema econômico que eu gosto
desse esquema é aquele coloca nessa
perspectiva né que é do meio ambiente
natureza como base sem ela não existe
sociedade muito menos economia nosso
tema
é todo baseado em troca de recursos essa
dependência a natureza era muitas vezes
traduzidas em algumas Nações da ecologia
né que deixar falar de benefícios da
natureza a sociedade as pessoas Às vezes
a gente chama de recuo é de serviços
ecossistêmicos e que são isso não todos
os benefícios diretos e indiretos que a
gente vai ter do meio ambiente como
alimentação recursos medicinais energia
regulação do clima e por exemplo o
bem-estar psicológico que a natureza a
natureza nos traz né a gente depende
desses benefícios para existir sem eles
têm essa natureza não existe humano nem
velho nem novo mano né porém que a gente
faz a gente não separa tudo o resto que
vive nesse planeta a gente destrói o
sistema Ecológico que na verdade é o
produtor dos benefícios que a gente
precisa para nossa existência um pouco
contraditório eu acho acho que é
interessante a simplificar alguns desses
benefícios
eu queria falar um pouco desse bem-estar
psicológico que é uma coisa palpável e
atual a está na natureza nos a calma né
ter contato com tudo que vive ela deixa
a gente reduz Nossa estreia de a gente
melhor tão presente o cores luz natural
formas naturais a espécies que em com a
gente faz bem acho que o confinamento
estudo ficou muito Evidente né era um
lucro a gente tem um jardim então a
planta tem uma um apartamento com uma
bela vista isso comprovados
cientificamente né traz um benefício E
aí está sendo aplicado também hoje na
arquitetura na cidade urbanismo a um
exemplo é esse hospital em Cingapura que
eles integraram o projeto vários
elementos naturais então tem muita
vegetação já né a gente vai trabalhar
com as essa luz com os quartos com
acesso a elementos naturais a sessão
solo trazer então espécies colonizadoras
pássaros né então esse vínculo com a
natureza é bem forte as cores também são
cores do ecossistema natural Então o que
a gente tem
com a natureza fazendo uma redução de
CEP de stress e acelerando o processo de
cura física né então são benefícios que
não são fáceis de pôr na ponta do lápis
mas que existem e isso acontecer também
e urbanismo no organismo a gente vai
comprar hoje muitos projetos de
renaturalização das Artes neh porém às
vezes a gente acaba se Trabalhando um
pouco na hora de fazer essas coisas a
gente entende esses vínculos de uma
forma um pouco errada e essas fotos lá
que vocês estão vendo são exemplos de
inserções de natureza um pouco
contraditório não é uma natureza-morta
humano feliz a plástica que
provavelmente no final da história tem
um impacto muito grande mas por que que
a gente faz isso né Porque que a gente
vai usar essa natureza plástica e o
viver caro o vídeo tá fora de nosso
controle pode do trabalho e pode ir para
verde o ano inteiro ele pode sujar a
esquece manter nessa posição de controle
de que o benefício Mas a gente não quer
o estresse que vem com ele né se lembra
uma história no quando eu tinha uma skin
o que a gente tava reformando e teve uma
proposta para fazer um canto de descanso
que ia ter uma grama sintética né quando
entendia muito bem tudo isso mas eu
lembro que muito irritado eu vou
estivesse grama sintética eu saía eles
vão ter grama sintética graças a Deus
mas isso já me perturbava sabe É muito
lógico outro exemplo dessa relação um
pouco deturpado a nossa com a natureza
que a gente representa a questão da
violência animal se você perguntar
qualquer pessoas que que ela acha
entende por violência animal da algum
exemplo vai falar de um cachorro
maltratado arara que foi contrabando de
água no máximo tinha falado os animais
têm de cobre as bolhas as lágrimas
abatedouros foi pouquíssima gente vai
citar como exemplo de violência matar
uma cobra que entrou na sua casa o
vizinho jogou o saco no sal sua tia que
mata morcego no rancho ou então ela ser
avó que não aguentava mas calçada suja
de folhas envenenou a árvore do vizinho
até quando a gente fala de violência
a compreensão é pautada né Não sei diz
que a gente tem afeto e não realmente em
tudo aquilo que é Vivo que é importante
funcionamento do ecossistema
é o que eu quero ressaltar não é que a
gente precisa parar de viver como como a
gente vive né proteger as espécies
fechar elas reserva e admirar elas a
gente se encontrar na verdade um meio
voltando à história da engenharia não
sei como pastor de criar condições para
a vida e parar de criar condições para a
morte né criar um jeito de coisas tipo
as outras espécies desse pai essa
dualidade entre nós e eles né amo fazer
criar mecanismos para legitimar a voz
desses seres vivos e não-vivos dentro
das suas invenções humanas que a
sociedade que é o sistema econômico
porque só reconectando homem-natureza
que a nossa sociedade vai ter um novo
amanhã o que é legal é que o novo mano
tá fazendo isso eu acho que é um pouco
devagar ainda mas tem que ser tipos de
esperança que estão aparecendo e que são
legais eu queria falar de duas
especificamente a primeira delas é uma
teoria aplicada em arquitetura e
urbanismo chama design regenerativo né
que
E aí encontrados ele tem muitas
definições diferentes mas uma abordagem
que eu gosto é que não importa o projeto
que a gente vai construir o resultado
dele tem que ser uma sociedade com mais
benefícios e um ecossistema com mais
benefício benefícios positivos né então
a gente vai tentar produzir a
coexistência coevolução entre a fazer a
sociedade evoluir ao mesmo tempo que o
ecossistema evolui e não comente faz
hoje fazer a sociedade evoluir E a
detrimento da evolução da deteriorização
do ecossistema é uma coisa bem
desafiadora de pôr na prática hoje a
gente tem alguns selos por exemplo de
construção sustentável tento fazer como
líder no rio challenge que é um verdade
ou desafio do Fred viu né produzindo e
um projeto simpático esse bairro né na
Austrália chama pedra no bairro pequeno
com 27 casas e que ele foca nisso ele
foca em criar condições para a vida
trazer impactos positivos para a
sociedade para ecossistema recuperar um
gene
e esse esse local sócio ecossistema a
gente sabe como fazer isso a gente tem
tecnologia a gente com essa técnica
gente precisa de uma mudança de
paradigma uma mudança na nossa processo
de escolha né de criação de projetos
segundo tema é a a questão do direito
jurídico de a antes não vivos como Rios
por exemplo Nova Zelândia tem um caso
bem interessante sobre isso recentemente
depois de um longo processo um rio teve
o direito jurídico dele reconhecido
então ele é reconhecido como um ente
vivo A então além deles só por exemplo
ser protegido por uma manifestação ele
ganha poderes ele pode ser representado
no processo jurídico por exemplo algumas
bem concretas curta uma rodovia que vai
ser construída vai ter a rodovia passar
na casa da tia Joaquina e em cima do Rio
até Joaquina vai ser consultado vai
falar que são os problemas dela vai ser
provavelmente embolsados foi
desapropriada e a mesma coisa vai ter
que conhecer corri ele vai ter que ser
representado alguém vai ter que tentar
traduzir
e o salsão o que é de positivo e
negativo para ele não é uma nova
ferramenta ela tentar incluir isso nosso
sistema coisas que até hoje eu não são
marginais nessa Sofia consequência então
colocar uma imagem falava eu acho que
você pensar a condição dos não-humanos
né dente para nossa cidade não só na
cidade mas nesse planeta que a gente
chama de lar final das contas aquela
planta que você esquece de molhar Tá
viva quintal que você cimentou aqui não
vai ter para a água é um problema e as
formigas que estão na sua cozinha porque
se esqueceu um pote de leite condensado
em cima da pia Elas têm uma razão existe
talvez você tenha tem direito talvez
elas até tem um cultura e no final da
história é certo de açúcar faz mal e
inseticida que você vai usar para matar
elas também